pierre moscovici commissaire européen
aux affaires économiques et financières
est avec nous bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation donc
pour répondre
comme chaque semaine dans preuve par 3 à
3 grandes questions premièrement l'union
européenne face à une avalanche de crise
joue aujourd'hui sa dernière chance
c'est vous qui le dites alors peut-elle
échapper à l'explosion vous nous le dira
et deuxième question la commission
européenne n'affiche pas le même
optimisme pas tout à fait un et que
paris sur la croissance et la baisse du
déficit l'objectif étant d'arriver enfin
aux 3% déficit en 2017 mais le
gouvernement
on le voit qu'ils signent des chèques et
le chef de l'état qui envisage des
baisses d'impôts joue-t-il avec le feu
par manque de sérieux vous le dirai tout
à l'heure à lucile malandain de l'
agence france-presse enfin troisième
question
françois hollande a convoqué aujourd'hui
les mânes de la gauche à ses deux jours
anniversaires le 80e anniversaire du
front populaire
mais peut-il encore l'incarner quand le
sentiment de trahison semble dominer
aujourd'hui un chez les électeurs de
gauche et chez beaucoup d'élus également
vous répondrai tout à l'heure à perrine
tarneaud de public sénat
les premières questions donc car
moscovici l'union européenne joue tel sa
survie aujourd'hui vous parler de sa
dernière chance
oui c'est vrai que nous sommes
confrontés à un nombre de crise
absolument sans précédent on dit
toujours que l'europe progresse on écrit
c'est vrai enfin là vous avez la crise
des réfugiés qui est comme une crise
absolument existentielle vous avez la
menace terroriste vous avez la tente
dans laquelle nous sommes
du référendum sur le break site vous
avez la crise grecque qui mobilise je
suis moi le négociateur pour la
commission européenne d'un accord avec
la grèce qu elle souhaite parvenir à
trouver vraiment dans la semaine qui
vient avec d'incertitudes donc dans un
port un pays qui épargnerait est frappée
par une terrible crise humanitaire avait
tiré le mans et il ya la crise
économique et la crise humanitaire il ya
des besoins de conclure ce programme et
enfin il ya toujours la crise économique
et sociale
elle n'est plus là j'ai donné ce matin
les prévisions de croissance de
printemps de la commission européenne
nous sommes dans la quatrième année de
reprise maintenant la croissance est
installé le chômage recule j'imagine
qu'on en reparlera par l'explosion mais
les défis mais tout de même les équipes
sociaux sont puissants et quand vous
avez des taux de chômage qui continue
d'être supérieure à 10% dans la zone
euro et vite
a man ça crée une instabilité et tout ça
débouche sur une menace commune à nos
démocraties nas de du populisme la
montée des extrêmes et en particulier
stremme droite
le repli sur soi et quand je vois madame
le pen avoir comme slogan non à l'union
européenne
et oui à la france je me dis que là on
est dans le contresens absolu parce que
la france est au coeur de l'europe parce
que l'europe et la france c'est la même
chose parce que l'europe n'est pas une
politique extérieure une politique
étrangère et et je me dis qu il y a un
défi commun qui est de combattre les
populistes et je me dis aussi c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis là qu'il
faut que les pro-européens et sortent de
leur timidité n'est pas leurs pondeuses
et l'europe fier et surtout propose des
solutions parce que aucun des défis que
j'ai énoncé n'a de solution européenne
on va rester d'abord sur marine le pen
puisque vous l'évoquez aujourd'hui c'est
assez rare angela merkel s'exprime
rarement sur la politique intérieure
française
elle dit qu'elle va s'engager pour
lutter contre le front national est ce
que c'est une démarche bienvenue de sa
part s'agit pas commenter le fait de
forcer les bienvenus parce que je sais
ce que je sais vous les avez dénoncé ce
que je suis arrivée là vous avez
l'allier gala merkel je sais pour aller
souvent à berlin c'est à quel point la
montée des extrêmes en france mais aussi
maintenant en allemagne avec l'afd
angoisses nos amis allemands
il ya chez eux une mémoire collective kg
mémoire des années 30 il ya surtout une
culpabilité ou en tout cas le désir que
ne recommence jamais les atroces dérives
qui ont amené au nazisme et il y a la
conviction qu'il faut tout faire par
l'europe pour que jamais on ne retrouve
la menace du nationalisme quelqu'un
disait mitterrand
oui le nationalisme c'est la guerre
comment ghana doit qu'elle peut
contribuer à ce combat contre le front
national aujourd'hui en faisant vos en
faisant en sorte que l'europe soit une
europe forte
ancré dans ses valeurs il s'agit pas
pour elle j'imagine de s'immiscer dans
le débat politique à gaza mais on a pu
déceler policier est ici lutte contre le
fn c'est ce qu'elle dit on verra comment
elle fait mais je ne crois pas que ce
soit tellement ça mais c'est surtout
faire en sorte de convaincre à nouveau
que l'europe et la réponse est la
solution
et je pense que si elle fait ça c'est
aussi parce qu'elle voit que les
populismes justement ne sont pas un
privilège triste privilège français elle
voit qu'en autriche 3 1 et voit comme
l'autriche à la présidentielle au
premier tour le candidat il faudra fait
35% elle voit life des montées et
enfants que je pense qu'il est
nécessaire en effet que les pro
européens agissent et pourquoi pas
ensemble moi de ce point de vue là je ne
suis pas totalement choqués ou je ne
suis pas choqué parce que je pense que
il ya des valeurs communes que nous
devons défendre
il ya des combats européen ou
paneuropéen il ya les partis qui sont
des partis européens
il y a des valeurs qui sont des valeurs
européennes combat européen contre le
front national en france à un combat
européen contre le populisme dont la
française et le front national
oui et de la même façon que pour ma part
je surveille de près ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays d'europe
si les britanniques à la fin du mois de
juin vote la sortie de l'union
européenne est ce que là ça ne va pas
être une incroyable opportunité pour
marine le pen qui l'a pourrait sans
doute faire exploser son fameux plafond
de verre est ce que c'est votre frein
c'est peut-être son rêve et vos
et mes jeux de l'es22 de réponse à la
première c'est que j'ai le souhait et
j'ai la conviction que le royaume uni
restera dans une europe unie parce que
c'est l'intérêt du royaume uni parce que
c'est l'intérêt de l'europe parce que
toute autre solution serait perdante
pour les uns est perdante pour les
autres et donc ça ne se produire dans la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il n'aura pas
échappé
marie le pen comme tout le monde que le
rugby n'était pas la france
nous nous sommes un pays fondateur de
l'union européenne nous nous sommes un
pays pour laquelle pour lequel la
construction européenne a été construite
c'est bien la réconciliation
franco-allemande qui est là il nous
enfin nous sommes un pays coeur de la
zone euro nous avons non seulement en
commun l'union européenne s'ils ont
dévoilé en interne a aussi l'euro et les
français dont je vois vraiment avec
inquiétude la montée du sentiment
eurosceptique chez eux
les français savent que le rôle et
protège et les défend et les français
sont attachés
quand on regarde les paramètres on le
voit attachés à l'euro dont marine le
pen se trompent les français ne voteront
jamais contre l'europe les français
n'iront jamais pour
une sortie de l'euro ce que nous devons
faire nous les pro-européens c'est
simplement mieux montrer en quoi il y a
les solutions européennes qui sont
positives pour les citoyens de ce pays
pierre moscovici vous évoquez les vertus
également les valeurs de l'union va
parler des migrants et il ya des mots
très durs qui sont prononcés aujourd'hui
par exemple nicolas hulot qui s'est dit
dans le monde
écoeurés par je le cite l'immobilisme
crasse de l'europe face aux milliers de
noyer qu'est ce que vous lui répondait
d'abord qu'il se trompe complètement un
mois je suis membre de la commission
européenne nous nous réunissons tous les
mercredis on se réunira à nouveau demain
matin on aura par exemple à traiter
qu'une question qui est celle des visas
pour la turquie
une des conditions sans doute de la plus
bonne application d'un accord avec
lecture qui permet de limiter les flux
de réfugiés
la commission décompose bon d'accord je
pense que c'était un accord nécessaire
qu'il faut faire fonctionner et qui
effectivement produit déjà de premiers
résultats et les mêlées fameux visa pour
les turcs un décret du chanteur nous en
parlerons démarre il faut qu'il y ait
des critères objectifs et la commission
est en train de les examiner
je n'ai pas moins à faire ce commentaire
la décision sera prise demain et donc je
vous demande à tous de patience par
rapport à ça on doit être par rapport à
la turquie et à la fois dans une
attitude de coopération nécessaire et
aussi dans une attitude de fermeté sur
les principes et et d'attachement à
certaines valeurs je pense par exemple à
la liberté de la presse qui est
totalement inaliénable inattaquable
j'étais en turquie il ya une semaine et
je les dis à l'après surgelés dis à mes
amis tueur mais en même temps c'est un
pays qui est démocratique avec lequel il
faut coopérer notamment sur cette crise
de réfugiés mais pas seulement qui est
aussi un important partenaire économique
mais est ce que c'est un pays qui a
vocation à entrer dans l'union un jour
pour vous cette appli candidat à l'union
européenne est vrai que mon sentiment
c'est que quand on est un candidat doit
mener la négociation de bonne foi et que
cette question pourrait se poser un jour
mais quand je dis un jour c'est dans un
jour très longtemps très loin et très
lointain c'est tout à fait hypothétique
encore faut-il que toutes les conditions
pour c'est à dire soit réunie
aujourd'hui à l'évident ailleurs elles
ne sont pas et ne seront pas dit ou pas
de sitôt alors sur cet accord un essai
quand mais leurs noms mais pour autant
il est important que les négociations
soient conduits de bonne foi ce qui veut
dire que à terme à 15 ans à 20 ans la
porte peut être ouverte si nous sommes
capables juste
de dessiner un arc de valeurs de
principes et d'intérêts communs temps
alors c'est pas pour demain c'est pas
poterie mais ce n'est pas de sitôt
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs pour jamais
en toute hypothèse le rapprochement
entre l'europe et la turquie le
rapprochement et la coopération sont
indispensables mais vous me demandiez ce
que faisaient leurs options je voulais
vous interroger sur l'accord parce
qu'ils étaient donc très critiquée
pâques la colle le roller l'europe je
voulais insister
1 réponse vraiment global sur la crise
des réfugiés
nous disons 1 comme madame merkel et moi
j'approuve son courage sur ce sujet je
lui dis que je pense qu'à genève les
alliances que je pense qu'elle était
confrontée elle a plus deux millions de
réfugiés et qu'elle eut le courage de
dire que quand des hommes et des femmes
sont menacées dans leur vie par des
régimes qui sont des régimes
sanguinaires qui les prive de toute
liberté il faut savoir les accueillir
moi quand je suis né justement parlons
je suis né je suis né mon père était
réfugié et donc l'accueil de réfugiés
oui ça fait partie des valeurs
humanistes de l'union par l'autriche qui
est pas un visage même de supprimer la
notion d'asile à davos les réfugiés
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
important que des accords comme celui
qui est passé que la turquie soit mis en
place
parce que ça permet justement de dire
voilà il ya des migrants qui ne peuvent
pas entrer chez nous il ya les réfugiés
qui doivent rentrer chez nous et qui
doivent être réalloués ensuite il faut
protéger nos frontières et enfin il faut
intégrer ceux qui ont vocation à
travailler écouter le sénateur
communiste michel billaut sur cette
question il réagi à cet accord donc est
entrée en vigueur avec la turquie et qui
ferme une route
si on ferme une route sans régler le
problème de fond
aujourd'hui on a des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui fuient la
guerre qui fuient la famine les
emprunteront d'autres routes parfois
peut-être plus longue et plus dangereuse
on a vu effectivement un nouveau
naufrage se produire dans les eaux de la
mer méditerranée avec 300 km de mer à
franchir pour atteindre d'hypothétiques
côtes italiennes donc effectivement si
l'efficacité de cet accord c'est de
déplacer le problème et de le rendre
encore plus dangereux il ira sans doute
des recommandations de notre part
peut-être pour traiter les choses
autrement
alors il ya des critiques d'ordre
humanitaire mais des critiques de fond
également de la part du sénateur michel
billaut rencontrer tout à l'heure par
faustine d'un saint genies puisqu'une
autre route pourrait s'ouvrir demain
déjà il est important tout de même que
cette route ci soient maîtrisés
contrôler et puis c'est pas seulement ça
parce qu'il ya non seulement un accord
ou ferment cette route ou si on ouvre un
autre canal qui est l'accueil de
réfugiés qui leur seraient installés
être réalloués dans le pays mais là où
il a raison et là où nicolas hulot a
raison je dis il a tort de penser que
l'europe n'a pas de réponse mais il a
raison sur un point c'est que cette
réponse tout être humaniste et
humanitaire ce qui veut dire qu'il faut
être capable de protéger nos frontières
je rappelle une des propositions de
commission qui verra le jour la création
d'un corps de gardes côtes ou de gardes
frontières parce que notre frontière
commune de tous était le protéger mais
il est important aussi de lutter contre
ces modernes négriers ces hommes qui
exploitent la détresse de ceux qui
fuient leur pays qu'ils le font à prix
d'or et qui se trouvent la mort en mer
et donc ça ça implique aussi que nous
force à nous force maritime soit
renforcée c'est une réponse globale que
nous voulons articulé également dans
l'actualité et l'avenir du traité
transatlantique vous suivez également ce
dossier de près après les révélations
hier de greenpeace un kaki un peu percer
le voile sur ces négociations très
opaque 1 qui dure depuis des années
eh bien la france sonne la charge
aujourd'hui vous l'avez noté
c'est non à ce stade pour françois
hollande et on écoute matthias fekl
jusqu'à terre d'état au commerce
extérieur eh ben il y également la même
chose bien sûr est un à corti qui tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
est ce serait un mauvais accord sur tous
les sujets que vous avez indiquée et je
l' ai déjà dit j'ai été le seul membre
d'un gouvernement dès 2015 a tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé et à dire ça ne va pas
et si les choses continuent comme ça les
négociations doivent s'arrêter alors
donc ses détracteurs dénoncent un traité
dangereux parce que donc il va rester qu
un certain nombre de normes notamment
entre l'europe et les états unis
est ce que vous vous intégrez inquiétés
de la tournure des événements pierre
moscovici avec cette france aujourd'hui
qui veut manifestement entraver les
négociations
alors si vous donnez 30 secondes 1 je
considère que le principe d'une
négociation commerciale entre les états
unis et l'europe ne doit pas être
écartée car cela peut être d'intérêt
commun un bon type nous permettrait
permettrait à l'europe de s'ouvrir les
marchés américains et soyons conscients
que les marchés américains sont
aujourd'hui plus fermé que les marchés
européens donc je ne dis pas fermons la
négation et c'est pas bien sûr ensuite
je les dis il faut que ce soit un bon
type autrui nous n'avons pas d'accord
nous avons des négociations qui ne sont
pas si opaque que ça d'ailleurs à la
commission veille
est ce que tous les états membres soient
informés au fur et à mesure de la façon
dont ça tombe de document et ma collègue
notamment 7e un somme seront très
souvent devant le parlement vient
naturellement il ya une information qui
est fait mais aujourd'hui il faut que
cette négociation progresse et elle
n'est pas un stade qui permettent de
conclure un accord car cela a été dit et
par françois hollande et par matthias
fekl et par d'autres
nous ne voulons pas d'une d'un accord
qui compromettrait aux normes
environnementales qui comprenait des
normes sanitaires qui mettrait en cause
l'existence de notre agriculture ou
qu'ils ne permettraient pas l'accès aux
marchés publics
voilà un certain nombre de conditions
donc sur le principe nous nous opposons
pas la négociation de tête conduite de
manière extrêmement serré et solide en
fonction de nos intérêts stratégie est
ce que c'est possible aujourd'hui est ce
que là est ce que les états unis ne
cherchent pas à imposer leur point de
vue et il nationalise ne cherche pas
comme disent les des facteurs à mettre
l'europe sous tutelle j'ai pris un petit
peu de recul avec certaines passions
nationales
j'imagine que si j'étais américain et
que je voyais le document européen
je me dirais non européens ils ont plein
de lignes rouges ils veulent pas nous
aider ne nous comprennent pas c'est le
propre d'une négociation et donc moi je
suis pas très choqué par le fait que
aujourd'hui les deux parties ne soit pas
vraiment en train de se rencontrer mais
on risque d'affaiblir leur apogée ses
premiers points d'avance le principe ne
l'écartons pas deuxième fois il faut à
mon type il faut beaucoup de conditions
et troisième point ces conditions
aujourd'hui ne sont pas remplies la
question qui est nous devons nous c'est
la question du temps parce qu'il reste
peu de temps pour conclure
éventuellement se tait tic puisque vous
savez qu l'administration américaine et
oui celle de barack obama s'achève début
novembre
donc voilà le compte à rebours est très
serré et quand le président dit
aujourd'hui ce serait non
je suis d'accord aujourd'hui on n'y est
pas je le dirai différemment mais il
faut en même temps que les négociations
se poursuivent le travail social
en tous les cas on ne croit pas un
barack obama avait qu'un en fin de
mandat vous l'avez rappelé mais il faut
mener une négociation très serré très
con sur nos intérêts avec nos propres
lignes rouges très ferme
un bon petit type ou pas de type voilà
c'est avec ces attentions aussi est très
fin très très ferme ce que barack obama
a rendu visite à l'europe
il ya quelques jours il est allé à
hanovre en allemagne où il a tenu un
discours pro européen qui a marqué et la
même l'ancien un appel au sursaut en
l'écoutent est voyou l'afad ici une
europe unie pacifiquement démocratique
marc viaud games top down est sauf et
orientée vers l'économie de marché
commence à douter d'elle-même
degen stocks croissants à remettre en
question les progrès réalisés ces
dernières décennies doit se savoir
l'accueil d'un week-end alors nous ne
pouvons espérer que le progrès qui
commence tout juste à prendre place dans
tellement d'endroits à travers le monde
continue est-ce que ce discours vibrant
de barack obama n'a pas signé finalement
que l'europe est en panne de deux
dirigeants visionnaires et engagé c'est
ce que j'aime en a écrit dans l'express
ouais un commentaire d'un livre de
jacques donation j'attendais d'eux le sa
part peut-être venir des initiatives
fortes à vous dire que vous critiquez
aussi françois hollande alors sont
absents première chose je vais y venir
après si vous permettez première chose
on a besoin de voix fortes
éventuellement venant de l'extérieur
comme celle du président des états unis
pour nous rappeler ce qu'est l'europe
l'europe ce n'est pas qu'un marchandage
d'intérêt l'europe ce n'est pas un
problème
l'europe c'est une solution l'europe ce
sont des valeurs est d'abord l'europe
c'est une communauté démocratique et
économique qui était construite pour
faire vivre la paix et vous savez quand
je regarde la physionomie de ce
continent
je vois aujourd'hui la montée des
nationalismes et le nationalisme est une
menace souvenons nous qu'en même ayant
un peu de mémoire historique sur ce qui
s'est passé dans les années 30
aujourd'hui c'est loin c'est loin
derrière et c'est loin devant mais ne
faisons pas comme s'il n'y avait pas des
menaces vraiment existentielle
dramatique quand je parlais de dernière
chance de l'europe
ces deux challenges pas et donc le
président des états unis il a raison de
nous rappeler pourquoi nous avons fait
l'europe
ensuite il est vrai ensuite c'est vrai
que pour que l'europe avance il faut une
commission qu'ils soient actifs
celle ci l'est je pense que la
commission bancaire est la plus active
depuis la commission delors qu'eustache
érigé entre 1,15 et il faut c'est vrai
des dirigeants visionnaires et engagé et
il faut en particulier sont pas là un
tandem franco-allemand qui soit
harmonieux qui soit équilibrée et qu'ils
aillent de l'avant et quand je disais
que j'attends du président n'aurait plus
qu'il prenne l'initiative c'est parce
que nous sommes confrontés à
telle cette crise j'ai pensé vous que je
pense marc une car les fortes du
président une parole forte à temps durs
j'ai cru noter tout à l'heure qui devait
faire un discours genou gauche on va en
parler quelle il avait annoncé lui même
qu'après le référendum pour ou contre le
braque site
il aurait à parler pour dire quoi pour
dire quel est le chemin quel chemin pour
l'europe entière pour l'europe avec le
royaume uni
c'est à la fois mon souhait ma
conviction mais aussi le chemin pour la
zone euro parce que autant je souhaite
que le royaume uni reste dans l'union
européenne
autant je pense que les pays qui ont en
commun l'euro doivent aller plus loin
plus loin dans leur intégration
politique plus loin dans l'intégration
économique
je souhaite resserrer ne pas resserrer
le coeur de l'europe c'est la zone
horreur
il faut que le coeur la zone euro soit
plus fort bat plus fort aujourd'hui on a
construit une romy est une union
monétaire
il nous manque encore l'union économique
et l'union politique c'est la raison
pour laquelle moi je propose a misé
l'économie et des finances de la zone
euro qui serait membre de la commission
responsable devant le parlement européen
avec un budget pour la zone euro qui
permettent d'investir 18 mètres chômage
de naillac un trésor de la zone euro il
y a beaucoup de propositions à faire ce
sont toutes les thèses que vous avez
exposé directement devant françois
hollande hier vous l'avez rencontré vous
allez le voir je le vois tous les mois
c'est un échange qui est à la fois très
professionnel il est prêt la gauche ps
verts et très amical fait le sujet aussi
on en parle on en parle tout le temps il
sait ce que je pense et je sais aussi
qu'il a bien attention hein faire des
propositions et je crois qu'ils osent
annoncé tout à l'heure et elles seront
accueillies avec toute l'importance que
revêt la parole de prison la plus
française
une parole français sur l'europe il peut
y avoir des paroles françaises
mais c'est forcément la parole du
président de la république allait
deuxième partie de preuve parfois
maintenant avec lucile malandain de l'
agence france-presse qui va nous
rejoindre pierre moscovici vous
proposerai à cette question venue de
bruxelles la france joue-t-elle avec le
feu par manque de sérieux
c'est à dire anne en tardant à annoncer
de nouvelles mesures d'économies le
déficit à 3 % en 2017 et bien vous vous
le croyez possible voire probable comme
bercy et mais c'est peut-être un
tropisme le franco français autre
indication du jour la commission se
montre moins optimiste que paris sur la
croissance l'économiste de l'eau fc eric
heyer
tout à l'heure par faustine saint geniès
analyse d'ailleurs la situation de
l'économie aujourd'hui dans notre pays
méconnu française a bénéficié d'un grand
coup de pouce par les éléments
extérieurs prix du pétrole légère baisse
de l'euro taux d'intérêt bas il faut
sans doute mené d'autres réformes
structurelles pour accélérer l'activité
chez même s'il ya une reprise on peut
considérer qu'elle est trop faible trop
molle pour lutter significativement
contre le chômage et donc ses réformes
là c'est sans doute
elles seront menées dans le prochain
quinquennat parce qu'il est très
difficile
en l'espace d'un an de mener des
réformes qui auront une incidence à
court terme
voilà donc ils donnent plutôt
rendez-vous au prochain quinquennat on
l'a entendu bonsoir lucile bonsoir donc
vous présenter tout à l'heure les
prévisions de printemps de la commission
européenne les prisons macroéconomiques
apparemment à nouveau la commission
européenne voit la croissance française
un petit peu moindre que celle qui est
annoncée par le gouvernement
comment pouvez vous expliquer cette
différence
exki d'abord l'écart est faible nous
nous voyons 1,3 le groupe français voit
avec 25
j'ajoute que nous n'avons pas intégré
dans nos chiffres les résultats du
premier trimestre qui sont plutôt un peu
meilleure que ce qu'elle corporelle nos
propres prévisions
et s'il ya un bonus je dirais tant aux
yeux de toute façon cette croissance de
l'économie française reste légèrement
inférieur à la moyenne de la zone euro
qui doit être allé lui 6%
pour nous cette année et 2 1/2 pension
l'an prochain nous aurions 1,7 pour cent
pour la france quand paris n'a pas à se
vanter
il s'agit pas de se vanter ou pas vanté
un peu de conviction si on pose la
question de savoir si ça va mieux
puisque c'est un peu du mal à mode je
dirais pas que ça va plutôt mieux lutter
mieux parce que vous avez d'une part la
croissance qui est maintenant reparti
avec une consommation intérieure qui
tient bon avec un investissement qui
repart et on attend sans doute le zeste
de confiance supplémentaire
vous avez des finances publiques dans la
situation s'améliore
on y reviendra j'imagine mais oui je
pense tout à fait jouable à condition
que les finances publiques soient
maîtrisées et que les engagements pris
soient respectés
je pense jouable de passer en deçà de 3%
en 2010 est enfin troisième chose
troisième chose permettait que je le jeu
le jeu l'évoquent parce que c'est tout à
fait important je crois que le chômage
devrait reculer en 2016 de 10,4 pour
cent du pib à 10 ou 12 2% du pib et donc
je parle de la dépression la commission
anciens aujourd'hui donc c'est une
amélioration une amélioration qui ne
permettra pas de résoudre tous les
problèmes de la société française
notamment sur le chômage
on attend sans doute plus il faudra
continuer mais enfin il quand deux
bonnes nouvelles arrivent
il ne faut pas je pense les négliger non
mais là la commission aujourd'hui
dansez dansez dans ses prévisions
prévoit ne prévoit pas que la france
passera sous la barre des fameux 3%
je vais je vous rappelle la commission
c'est vous on ne participe pas je suis
le responsable de la commission des
prévisions est aussi d'assurer des
principes de la france je vais vous
expliquer ça on va devenir schizophrène
je ne suis pas du tout schizophrène ou
pas du tout je suis commissaire est
totalement commissaire je suis par
ailleurs france est étonnamment pensais
mais je l'ancien musée l'économie mais
je ne peux pas me permettre
et je ne me permet pas la moindre
complaisance à l'égard de mon pays car
si c'était le cas la crédibilité de mon
institution la commission européenne est
la mienne sera émise et de ventes
atteint donc je vous explique
techniquement le dia tués chimiquement
vous devriez être très inquiet
aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer avec
les dépenses et ouvert qui sont
maintenant si vous allez 7 à vous 2 2
points premièrement nous donnons 3 2% à
politique inchangée comme on dit en 2017
à politique inchangée ça veut dire que
c'est en ne comptant sur aucun effort
fait dans le budget 2010
attendez on ne va pas on va pas y
arriver si vous m'interrompez parce que
je vous ai expliqué que je viens je vais
un peu plus loin il se trouve que chaque
année la situation des finances
publiques françaises
à la fin de l'année et de 0 3 à 0 4
point meilleur que ce que dit la
commission faites le calcul vous même
trois de moins 0,3 ou 0,4
ça arrive à 2,9 ou 2,8 par ailleurs nous
allons examiner en 2017
plus tôt en 2016 le projet de budget
pour 2010 est de la france et nous
demanderons un demanderont nous
demandons avec beaucoup de fermeté que
les engagements qui ont été pris dans le
pacte de stabilité soit tenue c'est que
ce budget de manière crédible montre
quel est le chemin qui nous amène en
dessous de 3%
est ce que je dis ce n'est pas on va y
arriver je suis pas français à ce point
je ne suis pas schizophrène du doubs je
dis que si il y à des efforts je dis que
si les finances publiques sont sérieuses
je dis que si les dépenses
supplémentaires avec dc je dis que si
les baisses d'impôts éventuels car le
plus en a plus qu'un pas été affirmatif
sont financés dans ces conditions la wii
passé de 3,2
en dessous de 3% c'est jouable et quand
je m'exprime ainsi atteint pas ma parole
personnelle c'est la parole de la
commission et je ne veux pas qu'ils
aient une suspicion je ne suis pas à une
sorte comme ça de le france est
transposée à bruxelles
je suis le commissaire chargé des
affaires économiques et financières par
ailleurs français alors quand je me lève
c'est jouable
c'est ce que pour la commission ne pense
pas que certains ne pensent pas que
c'est fait elle pense que c'est jouable
si la france est sérieuse et nous
demande réelle et sérieuse aujourd'hui
quand vous étiez vous même quand je
compte quand je regarde le chemin canard
ménage dans les décisions l'aller les
délinquants on signe des chèques là mais
tous les jours encore une fois ces
chèques
quand je suis devenu misé finances
j'avais dit à mon prédécesseur
commissaire la commission fixe les fins
nous fixons les moyens je n'ai pas a
expliqué à françois hollande ou à michel
sapin roi manuel valls les choix qui
doit le faire en revanche ce que je dois
faire moi c'est le rappelait qu'il ya
des règles communes et que s'il ya des
dépenses supplémentaires
il devra y avoir des économies
correspondante s'il ya des baisses
d'impôt elles devront être financés
voilà et ça je le rappelle a j'ai pu
j'ai plusieurs questions évidemment
quand vous vous étiez vous-même ministre
des finances vous plaignez beaucoup à
chaque fois qu'il y avait les prévisions
de printemps et d'automne de la
commission européenne que justement la
commission européenne ne tiennent pas
compte des réformes qui allaient être
faites et passer son temps à finalement
tapé sur les doigts des états membres et
notamment de la france en disant vous
n'arriverez pas à vos 3% 2017 comme
promis comment expliquez-vous
aujourd'hui que passer de l'autre côté
du miroir
vous faites un peu la même chose car le
message qui est passé aujourd'hui alors
par la commission européenne ce et on
n'arrivera pas à 3% en 2010 un premier
temps vont me reprocher d'être au point
d'une jambe je n'ai pas changé
les séances aussi que je ne suis pas du
tout schizophrène j'ai toujours pensé
que nous étions nous la france je suis
français dans un espace européen
nous avons choisi avec des règles qui
ont été votées par les parlements et que
nous devons appliquer est ce que je
demande c'est que ce soit fait de
manière convenable
autrement dit ça n'est pas à la
commission d'entrer dans le détail de la
machine et de dire vous devez faire si
vous devez faire ça c'est insupportable
et si on veut que marine le pen
finissent par gagner faisons le budget
de la france à bruxelles
mais refuse est ce que c'est ça l'image
qu'elle donne aujourd'hui en disant on
arrivera pas autres d'abord encore une
fois que dit elle elle dit à politique
inchangée nous sommes à 3,2 avec des
efforts supplémentaires
nous serons aisément en dessous de 3%
les aimants condition que ceux des ports
soient vraies et donc encore une fois
quand je suis dans mon rôle je rappelle
la règle
je rappelle les engagements de la france
je demande à la france de tenir les
engagements de son programme de
stabilité et si cela se fait c'est tant
mieux
nous nous rencontrerons alors les fins
commune c'est à dire les 3 % et les
règles communes seront respectés et les
moyens ont été choisis par le bilan
français il aura fait les dépenses qu'il
veut il aura fait les baisses d'impôts
qu'il veut mais il les aura financé et
donc c'est bien les balises et il faut
qu'il peut l'accord est ce que vous
redoutez que le gouvernement il ya une
pression est une partie sa majorité
renonce à la dernière tranche de des
pactes de responsabilité qui profite aux
entreprises là et il y aurait des
économies je ne voulais pas que je ne
vais pas me prononcer là dessus
ce que je peux dire simplement c'est que
ce qui est important c'est que la france
conserve sa compétitivité et je peux
aller plus loin là pour le coup à titre
personnel je pense que quand on a mis en
place le pack de conte de responsabilité
nous partions d'une analyse de la
compétitivité française qui était trop
faible et que une politique pro
entreprise dans ce pays est une
politique nécessaire pour permettre que
la confiance reparte et que
l'investissement reparte et donc je
pense qu'il faut autant que possible
tenir ses engagements là pourquoi parce
que ce sont les entreprises qui créent
de la valeur ajoutée sont les
entreprises qui créent de l'emploi sont
les entreprises qui créent de la
richesse ça veut pas dire que ça doit
être fait sans contrepartie se veut pas
dire qu' il ne faut pas s'assurer de ce
que deviennent ces milliards d'euros
mais encore une fois une politique pro
compétitivité elle n'était nécessaire en
2012 elle reste nécessaire en 2005 c'est
clair voilà alors écoutez bruno le maire
candidat à la primaire de la droite il
veut dit-il baissé lui les dépenses de
90 milliards d'euros un certain candidat
de droite met le curseur beaucoup plus
haut lors du prochain quinquennat et il
plaide pour la stabilité fiscale
les entrepreneurs ont été tellement
échaudés nos partenaires étrangers ont
été tellement échaudés par les
changements permanents de cap
la vie politique française qu'il faut
leur donner de garantie absolue de
stabilité notre fiscalité j'inscrirai le
principe de stabilité fiscale dans la
constitution
j'ai déposé en 2012 avec mon amie
valérie pécresse une proposition de loi
en ce sens que je reprendrai si j'étais
élu président de la république en 2017
il a été ministre en 2012 on verra ce
que choisissent les français on dit
toujours que franchement demain ce sera
différent d'hier laisse le maire évoque
la stabilité fiscale françois hollande
tout à l'heure a donc laissé entendre
qu'il pourrait y avoir si c'était
possible une nouvelle baisse d'impôts
ce serait la quatrième depuis le début
de son quinquennat
vous avez bien connu l'époque du
ras-le-bol fiscal parce que vous étiez à
bercy vous même ces missions de vos amis
qu'est ce que est ce que vous pensez que
cette nouvelle baisse d'impôts et
raisonnable et est ce que vous pensez
globalement que
c'est toutes ces différentes annonces
qui ont été faites depuis janvier y
compris aujourd'hui même une
augmentation pour les professeurs des
écoles qui doit être fait par balles ce
qui est assez conséquente
est ce que ça ne ressemble pas à des
cadeaux pré électoraux comme les
allemands général et vous relancez ni
sur les dépenses ni sur les baisses
d'impôts ça c'est des choix politiques
sont des nationaux la seule chose qui
m'importe à moi c'est qu'au final cette
politique soit équilibré qu'elle
permette de respecter nos règles et de
venir en deçà 3%
mais puisque vous avez évoqué le
ras-le-bol fiscale je me souvient en
effet que quand j'ai dit que les
français éprouvait un sentiment de
ras-le-bol fiscal c'est à l'été 2013
j'ai été critiqué
j'ai dû quitter par certains de mes amis
politiques comme quoi la poste est
formidable c'est nécessaire aux services
publics
je le pense toujours il faut des impôts
pour financer les services publics en
même temps une bonne fiscalité je suis
aussi comme faire la fiscalité c'est une
fiscalité qui est simple c'est une fille
ce qu'il était donc compréhensible par
les citoyens'' une fiscalité qui n'est
pas confiscatoire et c'est enfin une
fiscalité qui est favorable à la
compétitivité parce que c'est ce qu'il
faut pour l'emploi comme disait turgot
ou le regretté gars forts que vous
connaissez que moi michel grossiord
originaire d'une région que je connais
c'est un grand tort que d'avoir raison
trop tôt
mais le fait de continuer à baisser les
impôts dans un pays où les prélèvements
obligatoires sont à taux un des plus
importants de l'union européenne ne
paraît pas criminel ou fautif dès lors
que encore une fois tout cela et est
menée dans le temps de manière
raisonnable et financé alors l'autre
point pour soutenir la croissance s'est
tenue sur les réformes de structure qui
se réclament également par bruxelles
lucile et on en parle aujourd'hui à
paris plus que jamais la loi elle comme
ray la loi sur le travail la réforme du
code du travail
est ce que est ce que vous comprenez les
débats qui sont nées autour de la de
cette loi est ce que vous comprenez les
différentes modifications qui ont été
faits oui bien sûr je les comprends je
n'ai plus à me prononcer là dessus on
est un iman du gouvernement ni
parlementaire je vois faire là aussi
quelques réflexions gélédan de bon sens
je crois un pour la france une réforme
du marché du travail et est absolument
indispensable quand le marché du travail
est rigide compte ne peut ni entrer ni
en sortir
on sera devant ce qu'on appelle à un
archi travail d'insider qui est bloquée
et le chômage ne recule pas que c'est la
raison c'est la raison pour casser l'axé
la raison pour laquelle tous les pays
qui ont fait des réformes du marché du
travail voient leur chômage mais c'est
manière importante
je les cheminées ce matin et tous les
pays qui ne l'ont pas fait sont dans des
conditions beaucoup plus serré en termes
de régions du chômage et si on peut
baisser le chômage il faut une réponse
moi j'y travaille deuxième chose et
j'espère être là avec vous dire que je
comprends les débats qui ont été posées
la commission n'est pas une commission
ultralibérale qui propose de tout
dérégulé nous disons flexisécurité ça
veut dire de la flexibilité mais aussi
de la sécurité et notamment la
protection des travailleurs par rapport
aux dégâts du chômage et il faut veiller
à cela dans toute négociation dans toute
discussion parlementaire
enfin il est toujours mieux qu'une
réforme soit accepté par des partenaires
sociaux soutenu par les partenaires
sociaux pour le reste c'est maintenant
la discussion parlementaire de trouver
son équilibre
ce que je souhaite moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'en toute hypothèse
cette discussion parlementaire comme l'a
dit le premier ministre aille à son
terme parce que une réforme du marché du
travail je vais pas me prononcer sur le
point final est un signal très attendu à
la fois par les partenaires économiques
et par les partenaires européens
alors deux questions très ambitieuse
plus elle permet de répondre aux
différents critères que j'évoquais plus
elle est capable de permettre d entrer
sur le marché du travail
meyer elle sera deux questions liées à
l'actualité du cil la première
d'ailleurs lié à ce qu'on vient
d'évoquer la contestation de la loi
travail qui est fustigé dans la rue
comme une régression sociale sur la
radicalisation avec son lot de violence
écouter ce que dit olivier besancenot
c'est pour ça que mon problème c'est pas
tant les forces de l'ordre n'ont vrai
problème il est politique c'est la
stratégie du gouvernement je crois qu'il
ya une tentative de oued de stigmatiser
de diviser le mouvement
et puis de faire peur aux gens alors
qu'on est encore très nombreux parce que
le mouvement tient une tentative de
faire part aux gens que je vois même pas
de quoi il s'agit et fait pour le coup
je je suis un français qui travaillent à
bruxelles qui est complètement engagé
dans mon activité mais je suis aussi un
citoyen français quand je vois les
casseurs je me mets la platé français
dont je suis un français je me dis que
c'est absolument inacceptable et qu'il
n'y ait qu'une attitude par brocas
heures c'est la fermeté une ferme était
respectueuse des droits fondamentaux
notamment des droits de manifester il
faut pas confondre les manifestants et
les casseurs je trouve que l'attitude de
bernard cazeneuve
en l'occurrence et l'attitude juste de
permettre qu'on manifeste permettre
qu'on s'exprime aussi d'être sans aucune
forme d'indulgence avec ceux qui cassent
et parce qu'il casse aussi la confiance
qu'on peut avoir dans le modèle
républicain
la sécurité ça fait partie des droits
fondamentaux
autre question dans l'actualité c'est le
salaire du pdg de renault toujours au
coeur des polémiques il donc il a été
augmenté malgré le vote des actionnaires
le président du medef pierre gattaz se
dit gêné et tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron à envisager une loi
moi j'ai pas de problème je dirais que
le montant j'ai un petit problème avec
le fait que les actionnaires ont voté
contre je dirais les conditions de cette
amélioration et que quelques dix minutes
ou un quart d'heure après le conseil
d'administration entérine quand même la
rémunération donc là c'est vrai que je
suis un peu gêné par la procédure qui
consiste à s'asseoir un peu sur l'avis
des actionnaires quand justement des
dirigeants d'entreprise aujourd'hui ne
prennent pas leurs responsabilités quand
des gouvernances sont défaillantes
parce qu'elles pensent que tout est
permis et qu'il n'y a plus de
comportements en responsabilité en
éthique on est obligé de rouvrir
des sujets comme celui de la loi je suis
d'accord et ce que dit emmanuel mâcon
quand j'étais moi-même comme et des
finances la question s'était posée de
savoir s'il fallait ou pas légiférer
nous étions interrogés éventements et
j'avais dit à l'époque qu'il fallait une
autorégulation exigeantes c'est à dire
l'application d'un certain nombre de
codes de règles prévues par le medef et
que si cela ne fonctionnait pas il
faudra légiférer et donc il revient au
gouvernement français de voir maintenant
si ça fonctionne ou si ça ne fonctionne
pas je note que le président du medef
lui même se déclarent gênés
ce qui veut dire que les règles ne sont
pas parfaitement satisfaisante il est
souhaitable qu'on en arrive à trouver un
bon équilibre dans le cadre des règles
existantes
si ça n'est pas le cas alors oui il faut
sans doute pourrait-il modifier les
règles merci beaucoup lui si les
troisièmes parties de preuves par 3
maintenant avec perrine tarneaud de
public sénat qui arrivent pour évoquer
avec vous la situation politique de
françois hollande françois hollande qui
a convoqué aujourd'hui les mânes de la
gauche en ce 80e anniversaire du front
populaire je le disais tout à l'heure
mais peut-il encore l'incarner quand le
sentiment de trahison semble dominer un
les électeurs de votre quand on écoute
d'abord le chef de l'état tout à l'heure
à la mi-journée il s'inscrit dans le
grand mouvement de la gauche au pouvoir
l'oeuvre transformatrice est
impressionnante
elle est d'ailleurs pas autant discuter
qu'il y paraît la preuve c'est qu'une
grande partie de ce qui a été fait dans
cette histoire n'a jamais été défait et
puis il y à une donnée qui unit
l'ensemble de ces périodes pourtant
densité des circonstances très
différentes
c'est que jamais la gauche n'a été
appelé à la direction du pays sans qu'il
ait été lui même saisi de grandes
difficultés intérieures ou extérieures
et parfois parler d'eux bonsoir perrine
tarneaud alors vos questions à pierre
moscovici qui je le rappelle a rencontré
françois hollande hier à reste un homme
de gauche est-ce que invoqué donc le
front populaire c'est se donner un peu
une caution de gauche pour françois
hollande au moment où on l'a
de trahison c'est surtout rappeler
quelque chose d'historique c'est que
nous sommes au 80e anniversaire de la
première expérience de gauche à laquelle
ont participé des socialistes dans ce
pays et qu'il ya des leçons à retenir la
première leçon est très simple c'est que
hors de l'unité de la gauche il n'y a
pas d'accès au pouvoir la deuxième leçon
c'est qu'il faut aussi une cohérence
intellectuelle et idéologique qui
tiennent compte des leçons du réel car
sinon on se fracasse sur ce mur qui a
été le mur de l'argent à l'époque et qui
est le mur de la réalité
et chaque fois que la gauche a fait des
réformes l'équipe elles sont restées
mais chaque fois que la gauche a voulu
faire des réformes qui se heurtait au
réel à ce moment là elle était obligée
de reculer et donc il faut éviter de se
renier ça c'est la troisième leçon
on a beaucoup ri té in a besoin
aujourd'hui on a besoin c'est logique
social-démocrate d'un réformisme qu'ils
soient ancrés dans le réel des
réformistes qui soit également européen
mais d'un réformisme appartient tous vos
amis du parti socialiste sans doute sans
doute mais c'est aussi c'est aussi le
renoncement aux valeurs de touche je ne
sais pas qui dit cela je vais vous le
dire vous allez me dire parce que je
suis moi j'ai ce grand privilège vous
aime pas être tous les jours dans les
débats le parti socialiste est ce que
les gens d'avoir ton et fossoyeur de ce
quinquennat
pierre moscovici août et non ceux qui
ils expriment des opinions ils ne votent
pas les textes qui est compliqué pour
une majorité
en même temps ils ne représentent pas
les l'immense majorité des socialistes
et des sociaux-démocrates les ce
quinquennat est un quinquennat
donc il appartient au président la
république de démontrer qu'il a été
utile et puis ensuite on verra comment
cela se porte dans la campagne
électorale
vous venez bien des accusations il me
semble je m'exprime personnel que les
explique les accusations de trahison ou
de renoncement sont sans fondement et
que ce n'est pas une façon au sein de la
gauche
deux modèles des bras non vous ne
comprenez pas que certains puissent
apporter du fait que françois hollande
se soit éloigné à ce point par exemple
du discours du bourget on cite souvent
de proposer parfois des lois finalement
qui satisfont plus la droite que la
gauche l'a long travail par exemple
au départ elle a quand même plus étaient
applaudis sur les bancs de la droite
puis ça peut me parle pas de problème
moi moi de là je suis dans une position
un peu inconfortable
le commissaire européen je ne peux me
faire ni le critique ni l'avocat
françois loos mais je n'ai pas envie je
n'ai pas envie et je ne peux pas je
dirais simplement ce que je crois sur le
plan des principes
je pense qu'une gauche de transformation
qu'une gauche de réformes qu une gauche
dure et elle qu'une gauche européenne
qu'une gauche sociale-démocrate qu'une
jauge rénové et bien l'avenir pour cette
famille politique qu'elle a besoin de
rester elle même qu'elle a besoin de
rester authentique qu'elles vont rester
fidèle à ses valeurs qu'elle a besoin
aussi de tenir compte du réel est-ce que
cela s'est passé pendant ces cinq ans je
pense que honnêtement il ya eu une
tentative sincère pour le faire avec de
vrais résultats avec de vraies réformes
qu'il ya sans doute eu aussi des choses
qui n'ont pas fonctionné qu'il faut
faire cet examen prémices à donner un
certain nombre d'exemples jeu pour en
donner d'autres prises en appliquant la
randonnée mais ce n'est pas à moi de le
faire encore une fois mais ce qu'on a à
l'heure du bilan c'est vrai que manuel
valls a pointé un certain nombre
d'erreurs dans ce sens avait une
campagne électorale approche c'est ce
moment privilégié où il ya cette
rencontre avec le pays ce grand débat où
il ya d'une part le bilan et les
nécessaires et nous être fait le chef de
l'état et la majorité c'est l'opposition
mais aussi par le chef d'état est pas la
majorité lui même et je crois comprendre
que françois hollande réfléchit aussi
lui-même à ce qui a fonctionné et ce qui
n'est pas mal fonctionné
et puis il ya aussi et c'est une
deuxième dimension qui est essentiel
c'est la dimension du projet car mes
inventaire avant même la fin du
quinquennat ou à la fin du quinquennat
je n'ai pas la sensation quand je
rencontre françois hollande de trouver
quelqu'un need a battu il ne l'est pas
c'est un homme combatif il l'a toujours
été
il sait ce que c'est que la politique il
a de l'expérience et du métier il a
beaucoup de sang froid
mais ce n'est pas non plus un homme
auteur satisfait je pense qu'il est
aussi capable lui même de se dire voilà
ça ça fonctionne et ça ça n'a pas
fonctionné
et s'il était candidat il s'est sans
doute que le projet devrait être à la
fois le prolongement de ce qui a été
fait et aussi sans doute un peu
différent ça c'est la propre le propre
d'un bon politique et je pense que en
toute hypothèse qu'on peut lui faire
beaucoup de critiques mais les tarbais
sont les choses qui se prépare non je
dis ça je dis simplement que les télés
monde impression j'ai pas dû seulement
hier c'est adobe photoshop que je
connais bien depuis 35 ans j'ai été
effectivement le directeur de sa
campagne présidentielle
je ne suis pas son porte parole je ne
sais pas quelles sont ces attentions mai
2007 mais mon sentiment c'est que c'est
un homme qui est combatif qui est fier
de ce qu'il a fait et qui est aussi un
homme lucide qui seront candidats
c'est pas ça vous les gars vous dites on
verra comment les choses tournent
pendant la campagne électorale
je voudrais une autre impression plus
aisés comme ça on est sous la vème
république
la logique elle s'est toujours appliqué
et que le président république sortant
se représente à la fois pour défendre
son bilan et pour porter un nouveau
projet ça ne marche pas toujours pas
toujours été réélu beaucoup évolué
notamment à cause du quinquennat je je
je je pense que la logique tout de même
c'est aussi de se donner du temps et que
justement parce qu'il ya le quinquennal
quinquennat pourquoi at il été fait on
pouvait se dire deux fois sept ans c'est
trop et d'ailleurs à part françois
mitterrand personnes a fait deux fois 7
ans et les dernières années 80 des
années compliquées et donc on s'est dit
le quinquennat pourquoi pas ce qu'on
peut faire deux fois cinq ans c'est en
gros le rythme qui existe dans nos
démocraties donc l'existant du
quinquennat va plutôt renforcé l'idée de
deux candidatures d'un homme à la
présidence de la république et le s'est
toujours passé le président j'ai encore
une fois je ne fais qu'une observation
fait l'historique qui nous paraît
cohérente que fait chèrement de nos
institutions sortant est le candidat
naturel de son camp mais alors ce qui
est quand même une naturelle je dis
simplement que l'expérience historique
et oblige est nouveau c'est qu'un
président élu arrive en si mauvaise
posture
rien ou nouveau scrutin et la jeunesse
tourne aussi le dos à françois hollande
c'est un sondage conduit dans le monde
ce soir à sondage de l'ifop
mais la rupture semble irréversible
marie noëlle lienemann opposants
internes avaient candidaté une
hypothétique primaires de la gauche
réagit et commente la gauche n'est pas
au rendez vous des attentes des gens et
les gens semblent s'en écarte c'est vrai
des couches populaires
dix ouvriers du monde du travail ça
devient vrai pour la jeunesse oui c'est
catastrophique
oui il faut un sursaut faut que la
gauche retrouve ses fondamentaux et soit
en même temps gauche contemporaine qui
abordent des sujets d'aujourd'hui sont
non seulement sans rançon en direction
des bahamas est ce que j'aimais beaucoup
mais ça je vais pas commencer maintenant
mais ce que vous estimez comme manuel
valls qui est aujourd'hui deux gauches
irréconciliables
non je pense que il ya des gauches qui
aujourd'hui ont beaucoup de points
d'écart ya d'une part une gauche qui est
en effet ancré dans le réel d'une gauche
réformiste une gauche européenne et une
gauche plus radicale qui parfois fait à
l'autre le procès en renoncements que
vous évoquez mais non elle ne paiera pas
étrangers ne peuvent pas être
réconciliées alors dialogue est
difficile mais comme je le rappelais on
on parle du front populaire il ya un
talisman qui est vraiment indispensable
dans l'existence de la gauche c'est
l'unité si les gauches sont
irréconciliables
alors il n'y a plus de capacités pour la
gauche a accédé unitems on n'arrête pas
d'entendre des socialistes les télés
mais nous avons délaissé les autres nous
avons aussi un intérêt aussi un système
qui favorise cela c'est le système de
l'élection à deux tours en france avec
un mode de scrutin qui n'est pas la
proportionnelle on peut on peut ne pas
le critiquer dans la proportionnelle
on n'a pas ce talisman nuitées on n'a
pas le même fonctionnement
on peut avoir une plus grande
fragmentation on peut avoir des
alliances qui sont plus improbables
certains attendent depuis tellement de
temps qu'il y ait un centre qui se
constitue un gouvernement au centre
c'était l'idée de valéry giscard
d'estaing d'autres dodo
d'autres pourraient compliquer qu'on
revienne ainsi combinaisons aux délices
à l'heure de la catherine fait ses idées
de la perche que vous tendez la perche
que vous tendez effectivement sur l'art
en composition politique ni de gauche ni
de droite c'est un peu le leitmotiv du
mouvement marche des manuels macron
qu'en pensez vous moi je sujet je les
dis un homme de gauche je ne crois pas
que l'atténuation l'affaiblissement ou
la fin du clivage gauche droite soit un
progrès pour la démocratie
on a besoin de capacités d'alternance en
même temps ce que je sais c'est que il
faut aussi être capable de travailler
ensemble que la politique c'est pas une
guerre civile
je suis commissaire européen à la
commission européenne nous sommes une
instance politique il ya vingt-huit
commissaire 14 sont des conservateurs
huit sont des socialistes cinq sont des
libéraux il ya un britannique est par
ailleurs les conservateurs mais pas la
même famille que les autres et on trouve
des accords tous les jours mais
attention quand on est dans une
coalition et ça existe la coalition
coalition ça existe aussi en allemagne
la coalition n'est jamais quelque chose
qui précède l'élection
elle peut lui succéder et une coalition
n'est pas quelque chose d'harmonieux où
tout safadi et où tout se confond c'est
pas ça c'est un combat vous parlais tout
à l'heure mais mme merkel madame merkel
un gouvernement de coalition
ils ont une charte de coalition les gens
de la cdu ou ne se reconnaissent pas
dans ce que dit le spd les gens du spd
ne se reconnaissent pas dans ce que dit
la ceni où est donc tous les jours ils
s'ajustent ils s'affrontent la coalition
elle peut être obligé si d'aventuré
madame le pen était au 2e tour en 2010
est certes un sondage beaucoup de
sondages en réalité le disent alors à ce
moment là ce serait compliqué pour ceux
qui auraient élu un président au
deuxième tour de dire on s'ignore
mais ce serait le résultat de l'élection
et ce serait forcément un combat ça ne
peut pas être une confusion qui précède
l'élection
c'est en tout cas une hypothèse il ya
pas d emmanuel macron manuel valls dit
aussi un peu la même chose que son
ministre que j'aime là je ne veux pas
les départager mais ils ne disent pas
tout à fait la même chaîne jean
christophe cambadélis partis disent pas
la même chose ne disent pas la même
chose dans l'es10 pas la même chose
parce que lundi voilà ni droite ni
gauche ont fait quelque chose avant
c'est le sens de son mouvement
l'audi je suis de gauche et je peux être
amené à travailler avec d'autres dans le
cas d'une coalition ce qui est déjà plus
classique
nous verrons cambadélis a dépassé aussi
les partis politiques en toute hypothèse
que ce qui est important et ça c'est ma
position constante c'est que la gauche
rénove ya évidemment une satisfaction
par rapport à la gauche en france il ya
besoin de modernisation
il ya besoin de théories besoin de
théoriser ce qui a été fait il ya un
besoin de conceptualiser il ya besoin
d'avancer dans la gauche par rapport à
l'europe de n'être enfin complètement
européen et de construire également une
europe qui soit davantage marqué par les
idées de la gauche de faire des
propositions soutiens démocrates
j'y travaille moi avec martin schulz le
président du parlement européen avec
matteo renzi et donc voilà je crois plus
que notre avenir c'est la modernisation
de la gauche
la refondation de la gauche la
rénovation de la gauche que la fa 10
mans de la gauche ou la fin de la gauche
assène françois hollande qu'elle incarne
ça on verra je sais pas je sais c'est
pas à moi de le dire
je dis simplement que quand je vois le
présent la république je vois un homme
combatif et quand vous entendez nicolas
sarkozy dire de toute façon il y aura
alternance c'est inévitable en 2017 il
se trompe vous qui avez eu des mots très
durs pour l'ancien président de la
république il y aura alternance
un jour c'est ça mais la seconde de
démocratie et françois hollande lui lui
répond que l'alternance n'est pas
inévitable
on verra et on verra qui sera candidat
en 2017 pour la gauche
et pour la droite nicolas sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy on verra aussi si
l'alternance existe au sein des
républicains d'accord vous aimeriez que
le match soit rejoué en 2010 franchement
c'est pas à moi de choisir vie il ya des
instances qui sont prévues pour ça il y
aura des primaires à droite elles seront
elles seront finalement de la
terrifiante
elles seront passionnantes il y aura à
gauche et modalités de sélection du
choix du candidat vous êtes membre de la
commission européenne vous l'avez
rappelé qu'ils prônent des efforts
budgétaires des réformes de structure
votre candidat c'est le candidat de
droite
j'ai pas du tout l'impression d'être
devenu un homme de droite en étant la
commission européenne tout à l'heure par
exemple on parlait des déficits
la commission européenne et j'en ai fait
la proposition à une approche qui
introduit des flexibilités dans le pacte
de stabilité et de croissance qui prend
donc mieux en compte l'arrêt classement
les réformes structurelles ou encore les
efforts faits pour la sécurité ou pour
l'accueil de réfugiés
non moi je suis un commissaire de gauche
qui bâtit des compromis avec d'autres
qui le sont moins
j'accepte les compromis mais j'essaie
toujours de les pousser dans le sens des
progressistes parce que pour moi un
progressiste c'est un homme de gauche oh
merci merci beaucoup pierre moscovici
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation merci perrine pensera
tous et la semaine prochaine notre
invité sera un réformiste tient le même
sénateur maire de lyon gérard collomb à
la semaine prochaine